[Music]
hey guys happy Friday it is the end of
the week and I know we want to start our
weekends like right now so let's not
waste any more time there's so much good
new music to talk about today so what do
I begin now let's start with cardi B
hip-hop's reigning queen is making
history or debut album invasion of
privacy finally drop and it's already
sold half a million copies making cardi
the first female artist to be certified
gold in one day so how is she
celebrating
well her fiance offset surprised her
last night by flying in her entire
family from the Dominican Republic and I
can't believe that my grandma my
grandfather my art but that's a medical
record she loved but still car D is
spitting quite a bit about infidelity on
tracks like be careful and threw your
phone on the album
many fans think the songs are about
those cheating rumors swirling around
her relationship with offset I don't
blame them because I check these lyrics
out from through your phone giving off
some serious lemonade vibes there and
even name checks one of Beyonce's early
ballads about infidelity
Beyonce yo Mysterio Munnabhai um now if
you guys don't know resentment from
Beyonce's first album oh she lays it in
to her man for cheating and this was
long before she took a baseball bat to
his car and hold up but listen Beyonce
isn't the only person that cardi is
rapping about on this album listen to
who she's putting the moves on and she
bad I need Christie get you a bad [ __ ]
when I see one so really a threesome I
miss babe it's a [ __ ]
yep Chrissy Teigen and Rihanna getting a
little love from the 25 year old rapper
right there and Chrissy caught wind of
the shoutout and had the best reaction
she tweeted gasp drops biscuits
she's a referring to the cheddar
biscuits she cooked for dinner that
night
but speaking of Chrissy
her hubby John Legend also dropped some
new tunes which he called a spring pop
and let me tell you he's not lying
there's a taste of the video for his
latest single a good night featuring
blood pop
[Music]
guys it's already stuck in my head I'm
not sorry about it
ET's Kelty and I actually just caught up
with John took him to his first
SoulCycle class in fact were they
debuted the song and where he shared the
inspiration behind it now the lyrics of
the song I think it's gonna be good
night I think I just met my wife yeah
well the songs about you know you think
you're just going out to have fun and
you happen to meet somebody that you
think might change your life forever and
I've had friends that literally the day
they met their wife they're like I'm
gonna marry that woman and and so we
decided to write a song about it isn't
that kind of reminiscent I feel like you
told me that on the side of your gate
video you were like Chrissy is like my
person whoa we started dating right
after that but I don't think we decided
we were gonna get married - a little
later but I fell in love pretty quickly
with her okay yeah us too John us too
meanwhile my boys BTS surprised fans
with a nine minute video titled euphoria
theme of love yourself wonder now the
clip is as artsy as we'd expect from the
k-pop group but missing is their bright
red and bleached blond locks a handful
of them have rocked in the past
BTS of course has known to change their
hair color often and in this visual
they've all dyed it brown
[Music]
I love these guys so much
the video is beautiful but I got to say
I want to rock all those looks all
summer
BTS army if you're watching let me know
what you guys think of the video
and finally Calvin Harris has teamed up
with dual eepa for a new jam now it's
the collaboration that was probably
inevitable but does not disappoint
this is one kiss the way you move
[Music]
like God you guys I'm sorry I think I've
already in the Coachella mood I'm gonna
be popping into the weekend with that
one and I hope you guys will too but hit
me in the comments section with what you
guys are listening to I want to know and
of course be sure to subscribe to e
t--'s channel and we'll be back on
Monday with a fresh daily deep that's me
okay bye